is the um
psychotherapy assisted uh treatment
protocol that
you like to use um
is it dealing with a conscious mind the
unconscious mind because i did a
hypnosis session for the first time ever
in my life last week with this guy in
one of my men's community and that was
kind of a bizarre experience like
i noticed my aura ring picked up on it
as sleep like it picked up
picked up on it as rem and deep sleep
but i felt some
conscious during the experience i'm just
wondering what
what the strategy is with field trip
with that stuff yeah it's both i mean
the thing that happens when you're on a
psychedelic trip is it really opens up
the unconscious mind
uh and brings it into the conscious so
you can you know kind of like remem
remembering a dream and like a dream is
an
unconscious experience but you can
remember a dream and bring it into the
conscious mind
and that's exactly what happens with
psychedelics which is the psychedelic
opens your unconscious mind very often
you'll become aware of something that
you didn't become aware of on a neural
biological perspective they've actually
done
fmris which is a functional magnetic
resonance imaging
um work with people on psychedelics and
what they see when you're on a
psychedelic at least with psilocybin and
i can send you the pictures
parts of the brain start talking to each
other uh that either don't talk very
frequently or you know never talk to
each other and so all of a sudden your
brain is making these connections
across cross-functional areas of your of
literally
your you know brain mass and that's why
people all of a sudden will report
either re-experiencing something from
childhood or they'll notice like
music speaks to them on a different
level or color has way more pronounced
effect or
emotional impact because you have
essentially synesthesia happening
in your brain as a result of the
psychedelic and so often
people have memories or insights or
create awareness
that stays with them you know people
often forget their dreams but
generally people are able to remember
their psychedelic experiences
and then when you go into the therapy
you take what your unconscious mind
revealed and talk through it on a
conscious level
which you know if you go into the
psychology and philosophy of it most
people would say would then
you know affect your unconscious mind
afterwards but uh that's that's a sort
of separate conversation
interesting um man i got a lot of
questions here so um
uh the the the um
man uh let me start with this so
i talked to a lot of guys with the
regular content production that i put on
my channel because
one of the things that kind of pivoted
me with what i was doing i remember when
i was talking to you
you know about setting up this channel i
think it was 2014 that i did uh
you're like yeah what are you up to and
i was telling you about the channel and
i was probably around that time just
hanging out with entrepreneurs and the
rides and just kind of interviewing them
sort of thing
yeah one of the things that happened to
me which i didn't realize until
probably a good year after the fact was
i had all the symptoms of ptsd
from a uh unhealthy attachment to this
one chick that i was dating at that time
that i'd broken up with right
and um it took it took a little bit of
self-discovery for myself and it took
some
not not some but quite a few
conversations that i had to have with
other people
and diving down rabbit holes when it
came to
um human nature uh you know looking at
evo psych and stuff like that
and it probably took me a good few years
to really come to the realization even
then like you know to this day i still
feel a little bit of vulnerability to
like a condition that the red pill calls
one itis right where you can have an
unhealthy attachment to one woman when
you can't let go of something sort of
thing i see a lot of guys have it
um just because they subscribe to a
belief system that
isn't that doesn't accurately reflect
human behavior and nature like a lot of
guys will watch a lot of disney stuff
and pay a lot of attention to media in
the news and they'll think
oh sugar and spice and all things nice
nice and you know how could this woman
possibly
you know although the course of my life
yet there's men every day going through
the divorce machine that take their own
lives right
so um like with stuff like this
is this app is this application broader
than just dealing with
something like ptsd like is this
something that can
be used for um like there's a lot of
people on ssris you know dealing with
depression i know you talked about not
not particularly wanting to focus on
that but
how how broad is this scope of treatment
that field trip
can you know really participate in
it's incredibly broad um you know it's
it's
it's a little bit of science but it's a
little bit of terminology which is
you know in your particular reference
it's like yeah you had ptsd you know
most people think about ptsd as being
something associated with veterans but
any trauma experience um can create its
own instance you know they
they talk about how in the community and
this current scientific belief is that
there's no such thing as a bad trip
you know if you grew up in the 80s like
i did uh or earlier you probably
watched all sorts of like dare to not do
drugs videos and you know this is your
brand on
you know the frying pan yeah exactly and
all that kind of stuff
and or like people jumping out of
windows [ __ ] out of everybody
yeah exactly uh people jumping out of
windows after doing lsd and all that
kind of stuff
and listen you know the truth is is like
that did happen it didn't happen
with nearly the frequency you would
think um
based on what we were taught but there
are risks those are powerful molecules
but generally the belief is that there's
no such thing as a bad trip per se
um there are hard trips and there are
easy trips easy trips are
exactly what you'd expect you know
wonderful colors feelings of love unity
all of these positive emotions
and there are hard trips that can get
dark and scary and and challenging
um and really challenge your sense of
self identity
now a hard trip that can become a bad
trip if it's not
given with the right therapeutic support
you know most psychedelic therapists
will say like
if you encounter something terrifying
during a trip don't run away from it go
towards it because there's something to
be learned
your unconscious mind is telling you
something that you need to confront
and process um but if if you don't do it
with the right support if you feel
scared it can actually create its own
instance of ptsd
you know that's only in your mind and if
people kind of wonder about it it's like
think about like having a nightmare you
wake up from a nightmare and you're
scared right it's affected you if
you're physically you know your fight or
flight system is
is engaged um the same thing can happen
with a trip but it can go
much deeper than most bad dreams would
um
so ptsd is is an experience that's much
broader than
just uh you know being present and war
you know and
all of us experience traumas all you
know in the work i've done
you know and with irwin who's my coach
or
i don't even know how you describe them
you know when you're a kid you
experience traumas you have to how many
times do your parents say no to
something you want to do and so what
kids do is they kind of build up
emotional walls because they don't want
to
constantly be angry about hearing be
being told
no don't stick your finger in that no
don't pick that up
and so it's a lifelong journey to
process all of these traumas and
feelings and emotions and
take down those emotional walls
and to the extent that psychedelics are
opening your
unconscious mind to new experiences new
perspectives they can be used across
any number of potential applications and
within our clinics
we're somewhat restricted jurisdiction
by jurisdiction because of guidance from
the colleges but
general rule is within field trip will
treat any form
of mental health condition you know
ranging from the most severe
treatment resistant depression to people
who just have
adjustment disorder or dysthymia which
is basically they're feeling low they're
feeling sad and they can't seem to bust
out of it
um and all of them can potentially
benefit because at the end of the day
the mechanism of action is really the
same which is psychedelics by and large
or
rapid antidepressants they make you feel
happier almost immediately
but then they do two other things one is
they open your unconscious mind so you
can revisit things that may have been
packed away or that you're not willing
to go into
um you know and that your brain has put
or your mind has put conscious
walls against you can confront them and
start to process that trauma
and then thirdly they create a period of
neuroplasticity
so what happens is your brain when you
have consistently say depressed
thoughts the more you have a consistent
thought the more that pathway in your
brain gets cemented
and it makes it easier to have that
thought over and over again and so
essentially what
what psychedelics do as michael pollan
described it is if you can
imagine like a lane uh with
cross-country ski tracks in it uh
psychedelics are kind of like a fresh
batch of
powdery snow on top of that so those old
pathways that you're used to using
can get you know essentially removed and
you can up open up new pathways that may
be more productive more optimistic
happier um and so you have this period
of neuroplasticity where
the therapy really kicks in where you
know if you're doing the cognitive
behavioral therapy shortly after a
psychedelic session
and your therapist is using motivational
interviewing or behavioral activation
these techniques that have been shown to
work they just take a long time
uh you're much more receptive to that
and and so you can change your habits
you can change your outlooks
much faster than you could if you're
just doing cognitive behavioral therapy
so between these three layers of the
immediate lift
um the ability to process old
experiences and the neural plasticity
um that that's across everything you
know you don't even have to have a
mental health condition to potentially
benefit from that
you